now that we've had a little bit more
time to review Donald Trump's Attorney
General William bars for page summary of
the Moller investigation we're starting
to get a sense of the full scope of the
absurdity and dishonesty of it and we're
gonna go through it in some detail today
now later I will let you know
I guess I'm letting you know now but
we'll get into it in more detail that
the Republican Senate Majority Leader
Mitch McConnell has already blocked a
resolution to release the full Moeller
investigation report and this is one
data point that is increasingly
illuminating what it is that is taking
place here there's an attorney and
professor at University of New Hampshire
named Seth Abramson who put together a
really great Twitter thread down to the
fine grit detail of how William bars for
Paige Muller investigation summary is
essentially a total scam or sham use
whichever or both words that you want
and to really understand this we do have
to get into some detail and I'm going to
do my best to sort of ballpark it for
you and then give you some specific
examples because I want everybody to
understand it
I don't want people's eyes to glaze over
but I also want to do it in a way that
doesn't ignore the detail so William
Barr put out a four-page document the
first page of which were putting on the
screen for our audience and one really
important thing to understand is that
Donald Trump's Attorney General William
bar published not a summary of the
investigation William bar published a
summary of the summary of the
investigation now you might be saying
David you're already sort of losing me
here what I mean by that is that Robert
Muller did the investigation which
includes all sorts of raw evidence case
files testimony pages and pages and
pages of evidence
Robert Moeller then wrote a report a
summary we could call it which he sent
to William Barr presumably Muller sent
both the case files meaning all the data
and the evidence as well as his summary
to William Barr he
not half but let's assume that he did
William bar summarized the summary not
the evidence and included just pieces of
four sentences from Robert molars
summary of his own investigation okay so
it's a summary of a summary rather than
a summary of the in full investigation
data why do we care about that the
reason we care is because Robert molars
summary is only about decisions made
either to prosecute or not to prosecute
without the further underlying evidence
so I'll give you an example to try to
make this crystal clear but Robert
molars summary of the investigation
could say based on all the evidence
about obstruction I decided I could not
prosecute from but I also cannot
exonerate him fine however if we looked
at the raw evidence from the
investigation it might indicate that
Robert Muller had for example 80 percent
of what he needed to prosecute Donald
Trump for obstruction Muller gives bar a
summary which says I didn't have enough
to indict on obstruction you might need
95 percent to indict on obstruction but
bar because he's summarizing a summary
says merely that there was not evidence
to indict for obstruction and implies
that there was not any evidence that
Donald Trump Trump obstructed justice
it's tricky wording so many people
simply don't notice the difference but
it's extraordinarily important the
strategic decision that William bar made
and he has a lot of experience in this
as an article from Tom Hartman tells us
which we'll deal with later on in the
program Barr made the strategic decision
to summarize the summary because it will
foment the idea of it's very binary was
there collusion or wasn't there
collusion is the president exonerated or
is the president not exonerated and if
we actually saw the full case file we
would almost certainly see a ton of
evidence supporting criminality by
Donald Trump and associates on many
fronts
but likely not enough for Moeller to
independently make the decision to
prosecute there's a sort of analogy that
we could imagine with burglary
imagine that robert muller was hired to
investigate burglary and if you look at
his raw case file that lists all of the
evidence he might say okay the alleged
burglar was in the location was spotted
in the location at the time and the
alleged burglar was previously someone
who had provided a service it was the
Cable Guy at the house that was
ultimately burglarized and the burglar
was caught with some piece of paper that
looks like it came from the house that
was burglarized but I ultimately can't
prove this beyond a reasonable doubt
because the surveillance footage doesn't
show the burglar if Muller summarizes
that Muller would say I am unable to
establish beyond a reasonable doubt that
this individual committed the burglary
if bar comes in and summarizes the
summary you can imply that there was no
evidence whatsoever when in fact is that
just described to you there was evidence
but not enough to establish beyond a
reasonable doubt that an indictment was
relevant let me give you another example
of a really important semantic game that
William bar plays here if you look at
the last paragraph of page one of bars
summary it says that the special counsel
thoroughly investigated allegations of
conspiracy with the Russian government
to interfere in the 2016 election and
later it says that they didn't find
evidence of that this is an important
vocabulary distinction Moeller was not
meant to investigate merely conspiracy
if you go back to the appointment of the
special counsel and we're putting that
up on the screen which outlines exactly
what the special counsel is supposed to
be doing it says very clearly under
paragraph B subsection 1 that the
special counsel is investigating any
links and/or
ordination between the Russian
government and individuals associated
with the Trump campaign let's go back to
the bar report again the bar report as
written by William bar references only
investigating conspiracy conspiracy is
only one way in which there could be
coordination or links and its way
narrower than the full scope of what
Robert Muller was looking at and once
again because William bar is summarizing
Moeller's summary and not the evidence
all of the possible evidence for links
and for coordination simply aren't
mentioned by bar bar says conspiracy was
investigated that means agreements of
some kind for illegal purposes you could
have links you could have coordination
and still not have conspiracy bar is
being deceptive by being overly specific
which is a common way that people can
obfuscate underlying evidence and a Seth
Abramson says bar is adopting Trump's
very specific definition of collusion
the narrowest possible definition
referring only to the crime of
conspiracy and says there was an
evidence of that which justified an
indictment this is a sham okay now let
me give you another example of how wacky
we now recognize this four-page report
to be bar starts to mix and confuse
legal language which sounds sort of
innocuous to the average layperson but
it's not okay in the same paragraph of
his report Barr says that Moeller did
not find that the Trump campaign
conspired with or coordinated with
Russia but then when he quotes from
Muller's summary says the investigation
did not establish that members of trumps
campaign conspired establish is a term
with a very specific legal meaning
establish with enough evidence to
justify an indictment or to indicate
that a particular crime has been
committed
did not find witches bars language
suggests
0% evidence if you look at the
underlying case file that molar has
where as did not establish could mean
50% proof could mean 60% proof could
mean 80% proof it could be anything
short of what you would need for an
indictment sort of beyond reasonable
doubt these are legal games that bar is
an expert in playing which we're going
to get to later he has a long history of
this there's much more I couldn't
possibly cover all of it in one segment
or even in one show so in the
description to the YouTube clip for this
story we're linking to Seth Abramson's
tweet thread bottom line the report is a
sham every hour that goes by we learn
more about the ways in which it is a
sham and to be clear I've been saying it
for more than a year we actually have a
phone call I got a year ago which will
play for you tomorrow to prove that I've
been saying it for more than a year this
doesn't mean that Donald Trump
personally colluded with Vladimir Putin
we were never expecting that what it
tells us is that william bars summary of
molars summary is an absolute and total
joke playing a lot of the very common
legalese games that people try to play
when they want to either widen the scope
to their advantage or narrow the scope
to their advantage depending on the
circumstances one can be more
advantageous than the other and most
importantly if the actual underlying
evidence case files and report from
Moeller truly exonerate trump released
the report which Mitch McConnell has
already blocked as I will tell you about
later on in today's program let me know
your reaction and your thoughts I'm on
Twitter at D Pakman the show is on
twitter at david pakman show much more
on this coming up okay so I've been
saying for more than a year now that
whatever the truth of Donald Trump's
criminality is neither impeachment nor
indictment nor removal on the basis of
the 25th amendment our reliable means
for removing the President of the United
States the most likely and most
efficient tactic to remove Donald Trump
to vote in November of 2020 and to have
him out by January of 2021 that remains
the case in light of what we know so far
about Robert molars report nothing
surprising whatsoever the problem is
that it appears to me that Donald Trump
is very very quickly barreling towards
re-election in 2020 it doesn't give me
any joy to say it this is not and
i-told-you-so thing in the sense that
we've been saying the power of
incumbency is important even when a when
a president has a low approval rating
remember that half the country doesn't
vote you can win theoretically with an
approval rating in the high twenties and
Donald Trump's approval rating has
consistently been in the high 30s
yes Trump goes on these embarrassing
Twitter rants indicative of total lack
of self-control of mental illness of
serious personality disorders it doesn't
matter okay anyone who cares about that
behavior is already not voting for
Donald Trump and most of his base
doesn't care about that and then when
you consider that gas prices are
generally pretty low it's a silly metric
but it actually correlates to electoral
success particularly for presidential
re-elections historically even though
the economy we know isn't working for
millions and millions of people stagnant
wages although they've been trickling up
a little bit no health insurance for a
ton of people rising cost of living
massive inequality historically when the
unemployment rate is low and it's low
now when inflation is low and it's low
now incumbents get reelected regardless
of party whether or not they promise to
pay off the debt but have actually grown
it at record speed it's not a voting
issue so this is a big-picture analysis
this is not about Trump loving
authoritarians
this is not about how the white house
has been taken over by this swamp
filling nepotistic kleptocracy that
includes Trump's family all those
analyses are accurate but this is the
reality that if certain economic
indicators are doing okay short of a
huge and visible economic downturn or
scandal of the type that
not yet seen actually damaged Trump he's
likely to be reelected there are a
couple different models that look at
this one says Trump will win with 294
electoral votes if the economy more or
less stays the way it is now
others are closer one is an even bigger
blowout than that so the one indicator
that could actually lose Trump the
election is not about money it's not
about wealth or economics its turnout
and I've been talking about this for a
while Pat the one variable that goes
beyond unemployment and gas prices or
anything like that is turnout because if
Democrats can get even a modest boost to
turnout that could be all it takes to
remove Trump from office and the reason
why is that the election ultimately
comes down to the results of a few key
states a few swing states as we
typically call them even a couple of
percentage point boost to voter turnout
for Democrats over Republicans in key
states can change this from a Trump
blowout to a Democratic win so Pat I'm
not saying Trump is definitely getting
reelected I'm not saying anything in
particular about the Democratic
candidates here we're talking about them
separately what I am Telling You is that
the broader circumstances in which we
find ourselves
indicate that Donald Trump could well we
be barreling to a blowout reelection
here yeah I would call Donald Trump the
slight favorite at this point although
of course we don't know what the
economic indicators will be a year and a
half from now like you say turnout is
key I think back in 2016 there was a lot
of apathy people thought Hillary Clinton
Donald Trump they're both so unpopular
I'm just gonna stay home I'm gonna sit
this one out I don't think we're gonna
see that same apathy in 2020 I think
people do understand there's a
significant difference between the
Democrats and the Republicans especially
a Republican like Trump and I think
people will go to the polls because the
Supreme Court is important and
immigration policy is important and I
don't think we want to go through this
national embarrassment for another four
years well we'll see and for those who
are either hoping for or betting on some
kind of scandal at this point can you
even dream up
big enough that would actually affect
Donald Trump's bass more than a by a
couple of points which still just means
that's a couple points that have to be
made up by Democratic voters on the left
the the base doesn't care we can't wait
for a scandal we knew all along Trump's
not going to be you know perp walk in
handcuffs by Robert Mulder it was never
going to happen its turnout its turnout
and it's ultimately going to come down
to whether we get the vote out and get
enough people to vote that it doesn't
matter whether Trump's base gets out or
not because we simply have a bigger
bigger turnout and more voters that's
all it comes down to an otherwise expect
Donald Trump until 2024 so of course
we're starting with the major news that
special counsel Robert Muller has
provided his report to Donald Trump's
Attorney General William Bar we're
finally going to see exactly what's in
Moeller's report except we're not all we
have is an initial summary four pages
written by Donald Trump's Attorney
General William bar who wrote a memo
last year saying he doesn't believe a
president can be indicted for
obstruction of justice regardless of
what the evidence says he has put
together a four-page summary as he sees
it
Moeller submitted his report on Friday
Barr released a four-page summary
yesterday on Sunday and I've read dozens
of articles and analyses many of which
are missing key factual data in terms of
what we know and what we don't know many
of the analyses either with sort of
irrelevant incomplete or strawman
analyses of the situation so I'm going
to make an effort to provide something
of value here that will have two goals
reduce confusion and increase general
understanding of what it is that is
going on and my prediction is nobody
will be pleased with my analysis and
assessment here just based on the tweets
I've been getting over the last 24 hours
so let's set this up as I have been
saying for more than a year now if
Democrats want a shot in 2020 they can't
be relying on a molar report that is
going to lead to Donald Trump's
impeachment
indictment or removal because it's an
outrageous standard and it's a very
unlikely expectation and in fact anyone
who's been waiting around for sort of
smoking gun video evidence of Donald
Trump colluding with Russia that was a
crazy expectation to begin with and it's
something I've been arguing about a lot
with callers on both the right and left
on the show for the last year that's
just not a reasonable expectation it's
not a good political strategy it's
unlikely to ever come to fruition and
indeed that appears to have been
confirmed by robert muller so far
although of course we need the full
report everything we know right now is
based on a four page summary done by
William Barr Trump's Attorney General
who was handpicked specifically to
mitigate the damage of the Moller
investigation this is a sanitized
interpretation of the Moller report
written by the guy who said a year ago
you can't indict a president for
obstruction of justice many people
believe that we now know the full extent
of the Moller report we don't all we
have is a four-page summary from Trump's
attorney General William bar the
interesting thing to consider is that
imagine for a moment that since the
start of this investigation we saw
nothing the investigation was carried
out in silence and there were no
indictments all along there were no
convictions all along there were no jail
and prison sentences all along
restitution and to the tune of millions
and millions of dollars if on friday
robert muller had announced my
investigation is now complete we are
indicted 37 people or whatever the
number is here are the ones who have
already pled guilty here are the ones
where we already have guilty verdicts
here is the amount of money that they
are going to be subject to in terms of
penalties and repayments for fraud and
other financial crimes and here's the
number of years cumulatively that they
are going to be spending in prison
immediately the reaction would be that
is a stunning and overwhelming result
the number of indictments the number of
years of prison time the amount of
information that has been gathered but
because over time we
had one indictment and another
indictment and a guilty plea etc when
Robert Muller says this is as far as I
go I understand that it seems
extraordinarily anticlimactic but
there's still a lot of important stuff
to be gathered even from what William
bar has released so far number one the
Special Counsel has referred several
matters to other offices for further
action this confirms that the SD NY and
a number of other investigations are
going to continue and there may be
future indictments there are they going
to be for Trump colluding with Putin in
the cartoonish way that some were hoping
for from the beginning of course not of
course not that was never a realistic
expectation number two the investigation
did not establish that members of the
Trump campaign conspired or coordinated
with the Russian government in its
election interference exactly as
expected we we did not believe that
Trump was going to be caught red-handed
interestingly imagine any Democrat
getting an email from Russians saying
we'll help your dad win and then the son
of the can that it says they love it and
then they have the meeting and then the
Russians help and then your campaign
chairman Paul manna forgives polling
data to Russia and your hand-picked
attorney general says there's nothing to
see here but we'll put that aside for
now because in the end it is the sort of
conclusion that we expected Trump was
never going to be caught red-handed
colluding with Putin personally unable
to exonerate Trump from obstruction of
justice is another interesting element
of the report the report says that
Robert Muller evaluated evidence when it
comes to obstruction cannot say that the
president definitively obstructed
justice but also cannot exonerate the
president from having obstructed justice
that's important and it is being left up
to Donald Trump's attorney General
William Bar to determine if obstruction
of justice took place
I wonder what William Bars opinion will
be as to whether Donald Trump obstructed
justice and this is where you realize
that Donald Trump's appointment of
William Barr is working exactly as
designed Barr was partially
selected because it was known that he
doesn't think a president can be
indicted for obstruction bar wrote a
memo more than a year ago saying he
doesn't believe you can indict a
president for obstruction of justice and
now William Barr is in the position of
deciding based on the evidence does he
think charges of obstruction of justice
are warranted for the president I can
let you know right now it's not
happening it is simply not happening and
any Democrat who now is going to sort of
hang their hat on well we need to make
sure William bar decides to indict or
prosecute or whatever for obstruction
it's just not happening the guy said a
year ago that he just doesn't think a
president can be indicted for that it's
just not going to happen very
interesting element from William bars
report that's not getting a lot of
attention is that it confirms that
indeed it was Russians who hacked the
Clinton campaign in the DNC this was a
primary assertion that many on the right
denied all along they said no it wasn't
really the Russians who hacked the DNC
and the report from bar summarising
molars report also says that the Russian
hacks of DNC and Clinton material were
disseminated by WikiLeaks remember that
there were huge contingents on the right
and left which were saying there is no
evidence whatsoever that WikiLeaks was
connected to the Russian hacks if you
except William bars claims about
collusion don't you also have to accept
Williams bars claims about WikiLeaks his
connection to Russia if not you're being
extraordinarily inconsistent that's not
been discussed in any significant way
since yesterday's four-page release from
William Bar so there's a common refrain
from the right which is see Trump wasn't
actively working with Russia I want to
know who was saying Trump will be caught
red-handed having worked with Russia I
can't actually think of anyone who was
saying that certainly not on this
program we have insisted that Donald
Trump through sort of being a guy who
wants to be
liked by everybody and through previous
financial issues has been sort of lulled
into this situation of indifference to
people in his campaign taking help from
Russia and indifference to Russia
actively working to help him defeat
Hillary Clinton but the defense that see
Trump didn't do it is not really
refuting anything that serious people
were saying about this I also want to
mention that there hasn't been any
serious reporting on this summary which
addresses sort of what one of the major
issues which is what even was and was
not investigated here because the report
if you believe bars summary focuses the
investigation only on very specific
questions about Trump quote collusion
when we know that this is also much
bigger than that and on that I think the
left is basically United from what I've
been seeing in the last 24 hours
the left wing commentators seem
basically united on the idea that this
doesn't mean nor did anyone say Trump
has committed no crimes but that the
specific collusion caught red-handed
expectation for people who had that was
maybe misguided or simply inaccurate so
the next step is the full report has to
be made public period the the word of
Donald Trump's Attorney General who was
picked because at least in part he
doesn't think a president can be
indicted for obstruction that can't be
allowed to stand as the official record
of what is and isn't in the report if
there's nothing damaging in the report
Trump who now feels vindicated and
exonerated should want the report
released my guess is he'll fight it
because the full report probably does
contain a bunch of damaging details that
simply don't rise to the level of enough
evidence to indict Donald Trump on this
issue of collusion again the report
doesn't rule out obstruction of justice
it does put it in the hands of Donald
Trump's attorney general I imagine that
there are specifics in the full report
related to that another sort of point of
perspective here that that I want to add
is that anybody who's calling this and
or a vindication seems to be either
deliberately or inadvertently missing or
not understanding what's being said this
is a four-page summary which actually
says Trump has not been exonerated on
the issue of obstruction but the real
message is if you're hoping he gets
charged with obstruction in order to
remove him from office in 2020 I've been
telling you for more than a year now I
wouldn't be holding my breath and if we
can take sort of like a positive
perspective on this hopefully this helps
the left by confirming that the molar
probe was never going to be a
get-out-of-jail-free card or a put Trump
in jail free card I guess maybe better
said voting in November of 2020 is going
to be the way to remove Donald Trump and
now we have to make sure that everybody
understands that last thing on this I
want to just briefly address the portion
of the left that sees this as
vindicating Trump and it's not a huge
portion again most people on the Left
understand collusion red-handed was not
likely but Trump has done a lot of
things wrong including money laundering
and other crimes it is a little strange
to see some so-called leftists who
normally recognize that our justice
system is hugely biased along privileged
and racial and class lines except that a
72 year old billionaire president didn't
actually do anything because his hand
picked the journey Attorney General sort
of said so in a four-page summary and
what I mean by that is when the justice
system tells us that some black guy was
selling pot and it was dangerous and
we've got to put him in jail we
understand that that's the message that
comes from a system that is inherently
biased and we recognized that just
because law enforcement says something
doesn't make it true you can't believe
that and at the same time eagerly accept
the summary of William bar as an
accurate representation of reality as a
total representation of reality and
along those same lines when Trump
Secretary of State tells us Isis is
defeated we realize that's a political
statement we should be skeptical of that
when Trump's Secretary of Education
tells us Trump is winning on education
we recognized that she's a biased
political
actor so in the same way when Trump's
own Attorney General comes in and says
Trump is cleared based on my selective
summary of robert molars report why
aren't we skeptical about accepting that
as fact as well that element really
doesn't make sense to me so listen I've
agreed all along that it's the cover-up
it's the obstruction it's the ancillary
and tangential crimes that that's really
the focus Trump was not going to be
caught red-handed colluding with Putin
that's not actually news and the fact
that anyone on the left or right sees
that as vindication suggests to me
they're not fully understanding the
details of this initial summary of the
report and and please don't forget that
until we see the actual report all we
have is a political document from a guy
who said from day one before day one
from last year I don't believe you can
indict a president for obstruction of
justice I look forward to hearing from
you I'm on Twitter at D Pakman the show
is on Twitter at David Pakman show I
hate that I have to do this next story
this first story today but I'd be doing
something wrong if I didn't and it's
about reaction to the Moller report
which is not actually the Moller report
and that reaction and coverage of the
bar report has been truly embarrassing
and I'm talking about
reaction from media I'm talking about
reaction from many in the public to just
kind of get everybody up to speed again
we've not seen the Moller report Mitch
McConnell and William Barr are already
working hard to ensure that that full
report is never actually seen by the
House of Representatives nor by the
public I'll tell you more about that a
little bit later today all we have right
now is a four page summary of a summary
by Donald Trump's partisan Attorney
General William Bar and way too many
people on the right and the left have
abandoned logic and reason in their
reactions and their responses now of
course Donald Trump's reaction was
exactly what we predicted claiming total
exoneration that was written on the wall
twee
Quotes no collusion no obstruction
complete and total exoneration Keep
America great we knew that this is what
he would say
but just because Trump plays his
predictable role doesn't mean everybody
else has to throw critical thinking out
the window which unfortunately has taken
place in many enclaves since this four
page summary went public number one it
was too seldom mentioned in the constant
coverage of this that we have not seen
the molar report okay the the reporting
was all molar exonerates molar clears
etc what we had was a four-page summary
of a summary as I told you yesterday we
are reacting to a partisan selective
sanitized summary of Robert Moeller
summary of the investigation anybody in
the media or on my Twitter or wherever
who is pretending that this summary
actually tells us what's in the
investigation case file is actually
damaging the eventual ability to
evaluate what it is that Robert Muller
did and didn't find now because of
people on the right and left claiming
that Donald Trump has now been
exonerated they have participated in
priming the pump for a muted response to
whatever the Moller investigation
actually found if we ever find out the
full scope of that investigation if we
ever see the actual findings of the
Moller investigation imagine that they
reveal
I don't know Muller had 80% of what he
needed to say that Donald Trump
obstructed justice but wasn't able to
establish it beyond a reasonable doubt
everyone has already reported that the
report clears the president that this is
now fake news if it says something that
is different than what was reported
after bars for page summary was
published bars letter isn't even written
in coherent legalese as I told you
yesterday in detail and there are people
in corporate media and some in
independent media and of course in
conservative media and even in so-called
left-wing media to some degree saying
the president has been clear
an unqualified clearing exoneration of
the president do the facts matter
anymore
for everyone saying Trump didn't collude
with Russia but he's still corrupt I
mean that's right and this four page
summary from his attorney general
increasingly appears to be part of that
corruption as I explained to you
yesterday if the report can't exonerate
Trump which is what it says if Muller
cannot exonerate Trump on obstruction
that's a very damning report and to
focus the reporting merely on the fact
that Trump hasn't been caught personally
colluding with Putin which everybody has
been saying for more than a year
including me and I'll have video of that
in a second is missing the point of the
story
it is straw Manning and the number of
people who have contacted me on our
subreddit on Twitter saying David you
need to apologize because you were
proven wrong on collusion was I take a
look at this video from a year ago with
what I specifically said about Donald
Trump personally colluding do you
personally think that Donald Trump
rooted with Russia like just your
personal thought as an individual like
that that Trump personally was like
talking to Putin and setting things up
yeah like do you think Putin installed
some guy who doesn't know what he's
doing in our government and now he's
just here well hold on that that's too
different let's take them one at a time
if that's okay with you okay all right
question one is do I think Trump was
directly involved in coordination with
Russian agents I think the answer is
probably no I think that Trump was aware
that his campaign was talking to Russian
actors but I think the likelihood of
Trump personally coordinating and
anything is probably close to zero oh
dear okay second part is do I believe
that Russia installed Trump no not in a
literal sense Russia clearly had an
interest in Trump being the Republican
nominee from a pretty early moment in
the primary once he became the nominee
Russia clearly had a preference for
Trump
over Hillary Clinton and they had a
number of different tools at their
disposal to help Trump so when we
pretend that people said things that
they didn't whether it's me or anybody
else we also lose so let's stop with
that because even people in our audience
are embarrassing themselves on this
issue and then lastly anyone pretending
that this is over is really missing the
boat okay the Southern District of New
York is still investigating
Trump's inaugural has now been
subpoenaed totally separate from the
Moller probe the Trump Organization is
now under lawsuits for emoluments
violations the House Ways and Means
Committee may well get Donald Trump's
tax returns before we know it but the
the criticism here isn't that I I think
Trump personally colluded with Putin as
you saw a year ago said I don't think
that's the case the problem is that
every major news outlet and some non
major ones have capitulated or
acquiesced in a way that is just not
warranted by what we actually have so
far which is a summary of a summary from
Trump's attorney general even if we
grant barr the most generous benefit of
the doubt and i don't know why we would
given his history of covering up
presidential wrongdoing this was a very
cheap propaganda attempt by William Barr
to summarize a summary in the most
favorable possible way and use it as a
data point to claim that there's been an
exoneration to every person in the media
who played along with this over the last
72 hours you're a part of the problem
and this confirms to everybody saying
that the media is liberally biased
they're biased towards sensationalism
and towards a coherent narrative the
real story here the true one is too
complex of a narrative to make a good
corporate media story so instead it's
been probed for a year now it's
exoneration wall to wall for the last 72
hours and their coverage of all of it
fell embarassingly short okay so Donald
Trump and people around him and
right-wing media have been very quick to
say the Moller report fully exonerates
Donald Trump now unfortunately we don't
know what the Moller report
actually does because it's not been
released what we have the only thing we
have at this point is Trump's Attorney
General William Bar has summarized
Robert Mueller's summary of the
investigation where several levels
removed and the last level William bars
report is a very politicized level as we
talked about at the top of the show so
if in truth the full report from Robert
Muller and all of that underlying
evidence would exonerate Donald Trump
release it let's get a look at it if
bars summary of moller summary
exonerates trump and molars summary also
exonerates trump then the full
investigations case file must really
exonerate trump and yet Senate Majority
Leader Mitch McConnell is already
blocking a resolution to release the
full Robert Miller report we didn't even
have to wonder if Mitch McConnell would
do this because he already has this
wasn't even a binding resolution this
didn't even have a date certain on it it
was a non-binding resolution to publish
the full molar report at some point in
time and Mitch McConnell has blocked it
from even coming to a vote in the Senate
chamber it passed the House unanimously
okay
for twenty20 with some abstentions there
Trump said it wouldn't quote bother him
at all to have the report released
William Barr says he needs time to
decide if and what should be made public
but the resolution doesn't even say how
quickly it needs to happen they could
pass the resolution and Barr could still
get the time he claims to need he could
look it over and yet Mitch McConnell
still is not allowing the Senate to vote
on it how was William Barr by the way
able to decide in under 48 hours that
Trump shouldn't be charged with
obstruction on the basis of Muller's
report but he needs more time to decide
whether the report can even be released
Mitch McConnell says that there are some
security concerns with releasing the
report and he's right in a sense if we
see the full report we might
realize that William bar is working for
Trump here not for the American people
and that would actually be a pretty
serious security concern and it's
becoming very quickly clear Pat that
Mitch McConnell obviously doesn't want
the full scope of the investigation to
be known the most likely scenario here
is that while on a lot of these issues
Moeller genuinely felt as though he
didn't have what he needed to indict
that there is significant damaging
evidence against all sorts of people in
Donald Trump circles that's the obvious
reason why everybody would be behaving
in exactly the way that they are
behaving and the only question is will
we ever see that report I don't know the
answer to that well I certainly don't
buy the national security excuse coming
from Mitch McConnell but I would give a
word of caution here because we we know
McConnell to be a very clever politician
it's entirely possible that he knows
what's in the report
and it doesn't tell us too much more
than when we got from the William Bar
summary and it's potentially possible
that what McConnell is trying to do here
is to get Democrats to expend all of
their political capital on making sure
that the full report gets to released
and once the report is released if it
doesn't tell us too much more than
Democrats don't look so good so I would
watch out for that well I told you
earlier already William Barr summarized
Moeller summary of the investigation
which deliberately excludes by
definition any issues were damaging
evidence was found but fell short of the
requirements for an indictment but we
already sort of know that it doesn't
actually exonerate Trump because one of
the 4 molar quotes that Barr did include
in his summary was that molars
investigation does not exonerate Trump
on the issue of obstruction and you're
absolutely right Pat that Mitch
McConnell plays all sorts of political
games and he plays them quite
successfully Mitch McConnell outside of
people who follow politics is not
particularly well known but he's been
one of the most effective and
destructive political forces of the last
many years you might remember that he
successfully blocked Barack Obama's
Supreme Court nomination Merrick garland
long enough for a donald trump to be
elected and eventually choose a justice
for the supreme
he blocked multiple attempts to end the
government shutdown recently he refused
to sign on to this bipartisan statement
back in 2016 which would have condemned
Russia for interference in the 2016
election and now he's preemptively
trying to block the release of the
Moller report ultimately we may have to
go the route of House subpoenas and
reading the full report on the House
floor to get it into the record which
can then be published it could get to
that point I hope that if it does get to
it the house does do that but you're
absolutely right that in the end we
don't know what's in that report if it
truly exonerated Trump in the way that
he claims you wouldn't see so much
energy being put already into it not
being released but it would be
potentially damaging to Democrats if
when the full case file is released
there's no damaging evidence whatsoever
I find it extraordinarily difficult to
imagine that that's the case